foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsey show where we help people
build wealth do work that they actually
love and create real and amazing
relationships Rachel Cruz number one
best-selling author co-host of the super
popular smart money happy hour with
George Campbell it is my co-host today
number one best-selling off how many
times I mean you got a lot of accolades
oh she's my daughter too I don't know
about that yeah but you can keep them
going yeah just keep how many number
ones there's a lot of number one
bestsellers yeah open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
we're going to talk about your life and
you right in front of you Jason starts
us off in Austin Texas hi Jason how are
you
hello Dave Rachel how you doing better
than we deserve what's up in your world
um well I thought really behind the
eight ball I was wondering if I could
um put away for retirement and pay the
payoff debt at the same time
um I've been doing the baby steps and I
have currently now more than 300 to 128
000 worth of student loan debt I have a
car alone of 33 000 and
um you went from 300 000 in student
loans down to 100 and a quarter
yes way to go man yeah I was working
really hard how long did that take you
um it took me about three years wow
three years what do you make
so when I was in I said I'm a physician
so when I was in residency I was making
about 70. my wife also worked so she was
making about 72 so we were living in
kind of it was an awful one income
what's your household income now
So currently it's 290. oh man you're
awesome way to go you go knock this out
in no time aren't you I have nothing in
retirement so I'm wondering oh you're
okay how old are you Jason
um 35. oh man you're good yeah listen
you're gonna be debt-free in a year and
a half
yeah yeah
let's just let's just be real care you
make 300 000 a year you're 37 years old
and you have no debt can we retire Rich
answer yes
okay hello think about it really
okay okay
yeah I don't so keep doing the baby
steps just don't yes yeah don't yeah
keep doing the plan you're doing great I
think you're probably getting a little
fatigue Jason I mean after three years
of it yeah I mean after three years
you're just like oh my gosh is this and
so and you're and you're hitting the the
big ones now and so worse than that some
doctor friend of yours start giving you
Financial advice
everybody's buying houses right now yeah
I know every doctor you know let me just
tell you broke doctors are like broke
people in the music business it's like
most of them
they because they okay they're really
good at their craft and they think that
makes them good at money and they suck
at money most of the time there's some
doctors do a really good job but MDS
that are horrible with money and
arrogant about it are like a they're
like a stereotype in our world yeah and
what's hard Jason is because don't take
advice from them yeah because well and I
think you know because a lot of them can
err on the side of having a larger
income and so what can happen with a
larger income just like you've
experienced you talk about The Stave is
like it can just mask your mistakes and
your bad habits because you just throw
more money at it and it's fine until
something starts to happen and you start
to realize wow the thing I have built is
a house of cards and I actually don't
have great money habits so for you Jason
I think it's just this powerful imagery
of hey if I actually do this stuff and I
clear the debt and I do everything the
right way what you're going to do when
you build wealth is actually true wealth
like it's going to be on a really strong
Foundation because of the choices you're
making today and so very good again
everyone else looks like they're doing
it you you guys are going to be great
Jason I promise you will be fine yeah
I'm with Rachel I'm gonna put some gas
in your tank because your Tank's empty
but your car is awesome I mean you just
you need to because you've been doing
really good you've been I mean for God's
sakes everybody around you should be
taking your advice not the other way
around okay you need to stick put the
pedal down and finish the race man the
tape is in sight Sprint for the Finish
Line Jason right there and after you
guys again looking at just the numbers
I'm like and once you guys pay off this
debt to to your point Dave like that
you're gonna be able to build wealth and
you guys are going to be you're gonna do
your 15 retirement you guys are going to
be buying a house you're paid like
before you know it you're gonna have
money to be like okay now what do we do
with this extra money your network we're
gonna be able to invest even more in
other things right I mean like you're
gonna be fine yeah follow these steps
you'll be a millionaire plus when you're
40. easy
easy based on where you are right now
easy probably two million but if you
just follow the steps just do what we
teach into I mean just don't oh man
you're just doing so good I'm so proud
of you all right Clayton's in Kansas
City hey Clayton what's up
hi there how are you today better than I
deserve how can we help awesome hey um
so my main question is uh should we
start paying off my wife's student loans
right now or should we wait until after
she graduates uh there's a couple
factors and a couple of plans we have
um so we've got a ten thousand dollar
emergency account her student loans
currently are for 4 000 but we will have
to take out student loans for the next
semester coming up here in October for
another four thousand she goes to a
pretty cheap online school
um
the first thing you do stop borrowing
that's step one yes sir yeah so you got
the money to pay cash make sure you
still got the money to pay cash at the
end of our discussion okay
finish school with no more debt
yeah yeah so uh so the issue is that she
lost her job a while ago and we're
getting ready to have a baby in October
it's a wonderful one of my questions is
should we drain our emergency account to
pay for these two semesters
and then what do you mean how is she
gonna go to school Clayton and have a
baby yep uh so she's doing a fully
online school
okay so how
how is she going to keep up with the
work I mean like
um I'll just be real I mean as someone
that's had three kids
is it possible sure anything's possible
is it the smartest thing to do to go a
semester into school while you're in the
middle of having your first baby
I would if I were her I would pause take
a semester off yeah take it have the
baby you guys save up some cash make
sure she's good you're I mean you guys
are gonna be like zombies for about like
two months uh with a newborn so there's
no reason to rush all of this is I if I
if I were her I would just pause
for that next semester and you guys have
your family enjoy that season what do
you make
uh I made 4 433 a month what does she
studying
uh starting to be an elementary school
teacher
at graduate level
um
finishing her bachelor's okay so she's
finishing up her undergrad okay yeah all
right so it is uh it's an online school
and I guess the way it works is you it's
self-paced yeah what is uh uh how old
are you two
uh I'm 24 and she is 23. okay Rachel's
right if I were in your shoes I would
take a semester off you guys you can
work an extra job if you need to and she
takes care of the baby and let's enjoy
this and not try to run past this in a
dead Sprint uh just just take you know
and then you got plenty of time to get
back finish the degree save up and pay
the four thousand dollars but don't pay
off debt and then turn around go back in
debt and then pay off debt and then turn
around go back in debt that's a dog
chasing his tail that's useless don't do
that this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
personality is my co-host today Jade
warshaw one of our other Ramsay
personalities is doing a budgeting
webinar August the 9th for most of you
that's tomorrow and it's at 12 30
Eastern time it's completely free if you
want to learn how to do a good budget
particularly if you have a an irregular
unpredictable income we can help you
with that too all of this is built into
the world's best budgeting app called
every dollar
and you can get on every dollar for free
download the app but if you really want
to learn how to use it for free Jade
will help you uh with a few of her
closest friends tomorrow
go to everydollar.com budgeting and get
signed up uh and spoiler alert uh in a
couple of days we're gonna be uh well
like tomorrow we're gonna start telling
you Rachel Cruz is doing one of these
webinars a little bit later in the month
right August 15th yeah and these are fun
we've we're excited to do these because
budgeting is like it's it's the glue
that holds so much of this together and
it's such a crucial piece and it's a
piece that a lot of people sometimes can
skip over or have these ideas of what it
is but all the emotions around money so
many of those negative emotions can be
solved through having a plan and
actually being in control so we're
excited dive in with you guys and
there's gonna be q a portions so we're
gonna get to hang out yeah it's all for
free so Jade's is uh it's actually a
budgeting seminar is actually a free
marriage seminar yeah
married
yeah it's gonna it's gonna bring up some
stuff okay yeah hey question of the day
uh is brought to you by neighborly your
hub for Home Services they're the place
to find Reliable help for your home from
trusted locally owned businesses like
Glass Doctor Mr Handyman and shelf Genie
visit neighborly.com to find home
experts that are available to serve you
great company so today today's question
comes from Clayton in Texas I'd like to
move it to a nicer neighborhood however
with the housing prices High and the
interest rates High I'm not sure it's
the best time the only debt I have is my
house 145 000 left on my loan at
2.65 rate I'm confident I can sell my
house for 300 000 if not more at the
downfall is I'm giving up a low interest
rate for a more expensive house and a
higher rate thank you for your time
yeah I mean this is a this is a very
standard question a lot of people are
asking like hey I want to upgrade but
then as they do the math and they look
at the interest rate and over the life
of a loan you know we say paid off
faster than 15 years but a 15-year loan
I mean you're going to be paying a
substantial more money towards your
interest and so for a lot of people
that's making them hesitant but you guys
I mean My My Philosophy always with
buying a home is buy it when you're
ready it's a great investment we want
everyone to own a home we want you to
have a primary residence when you're
ready it's a great part of your
financial picture and so you know you
have to really be able to kind of take
the noise and everything going on that
you hear at the news and everything and
and kind of mute all of that and say
okay where are we financially and as
long as your payment is within that 25
of your take-home pay uh you're on a
15-year fixed rate and and if all of
that math still works for you and you
have a good down payment then you can
move forward with it but you have to
know mathematically yeah we're going to
be paying more in interest but I mean
Dave that's that's what I mean a lot of
people are they're they're pausing a
home buying because they're like gosh I
have a good right now in my current home
and if we move it's it's going to Triple
basically into a higher interest rate
well as long as you're at 25 of your
take-home pay on a 15-year fix there's
two things going on when you do that one
is uh you're going to get out of debt
faster than 15 years
okay two is we know you can afford it
yep that you're buying a house that is
reasonable your move up is reasonable if
it fits those two things Clayton you
should go ahead and do it now
okay because here here's the thing you
you said some incorrect things here okay
however with housing prices being high
no honey housing prices just are
they're not high they're high compared
to yesterday they're low compared to
tomorrow
they're not coming back down
when you say they're high it's almost as
if you think they might come back down
they're not coming down
okay in 60 years 70 years house prices
have gone down one time temporarily in
2008 and they shot back up
one time if you're going to sit around
and wait on one time in 60 or 70 years
to happen you're never getting a house
they're not coming down
you're buying a house the way it is now
and when you're ready that's right as
far as the interest rates go I don't
know if they'll come back down if they
do refinance
if they don't pay off the stupid loan
because you know what my interest rate
is on my loan zero because I don't have
a loan
so there's a good way to get a zero
percent pay the stinking thing off pay
it off and then you don't worry about
the interest rates you're not keeping
this thing around like as a pet you're
getting rid of the mortgage so you you
know number one house prices are not
coming back down if you're going to buy
this is best time to buy
in the next 20 years right now price
wise if interest rates are oh I'm
worried about interest rates interest
rates are not high
they're not high historically they are
higher than they were 0.65 right they're
higher than they were but over the
course of history right they're really
not high and so if they did come back
down then just refinance think about
what when you were selling houses in the
80s now Selling Houses in the 80s or 17
15 yeah yeah and they came down to 14
and people came out of their houses like
they did after covid trying to you
couldn't they're stampeding to buy
houses and rates were 14. and then they
went down to 10 and then they went down
to nine and somebody called me up and
said I don't want to buy a house at nine
I was on the radio then and I'm like why
it's nine as compared to 17. I thought
it was awesome yeah and I said you'll
never see six and little did I know how
dumb I was of course you saw six on the
way down to three but yeah but the the
three percent two percent interest rate
range was artificially created by the
government trying to recover from 2008.
the market did not drive us down there
the market has hovered around six for
decades a couple of decades now
in and out of the six percent range so
historically it's only compared to a
year ago or two years ago that they're
high so this is the time to buy a house
it is the time for sure to sell a house
yeah there's still more buyers than
there are houses yep it's still a
seller's market so get with a good real
estate agent go to ramsesolutions.com
click on uh ELP for Ramsey trusted
endorsed local provider for real estate
agent that knows what the flip they're
doing
it has experience that sells a bunch of
houses and if you're ready to move
you're out of debt you're buying it 25
of your take-home pay Rachel's exactly
right it's not based on all the noise
that you're hearing from your friends or
in the marketplace it's when you're
ready it's like I was with this wine
expert the other day who's one of the
most renowned Wine Guys in the world and
um he said I said what is that good wine
and he said do you like it
that's the definition of good wine do
you like it when you are ready you know
and so you know do you like it are you
ready are you in good shape are you
ready to make the move Bia is with us in
Seattle hi Bo welcome to the Ramsey show
is it Bia
yes I did say it right because right how
can I help yes hello Dave hello Rachel
God bless both of you and thank you for
taking my call sure
um I want to know if I should fail an
investment property that I own do you
like it
I do like it
okay why are you selling it
because I am in debt right now my
combined debt with Carlo I just got a
new unsecured loan so all of my debt
combined is a hundred and fourteen
thousand two hundred and ninety seven
dollars and sixty five what the crap did
you buy Bia
it's a mixture of credit cards personal
loans car loans and charges you've been
spending like you're in Congress for how
long
I did since I left the military I
retired about 10 years ago I have paid
off some debt
um but I still have that debt left so
it's a combination of one unsecured
Signature Loan and three other separate
credit cards is my total debt thanks for
your service
when are you going to when are you going
to stop overspending
I am in the midst of changing right now
which is one of the reasons why I called
yeah good okay because if you sell the
rental property and pay off all the debt
and you keep overspending you'll be
right back here in 10 years changed you
yeah
because Skyler's gonna pick up we're
heading into a break but uh we want to I
want to put you through Financial Peace
University because this is our our nine
lesson course that will walk you through
not just the head knowledge of what to
do but actually the behavior change is
what we're kind of keying on right if
you sell this and just throw the money
at it you haven't changed you can get
right back in the same issues you have
to change you and so this has Community
as coaching it has so many elements to
come under you and help you through this
new Journey if you will stay on a budget
and live on less than you make yes you
should sell the rental and get rid of
the debt but only if you're going to
stay on a budget and live almost in your
man
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
foreign
[Music]
personality number one best-selling
author my daughter is my co-host today
be sure and check her and George out the
smart money happy hour has a once a week
podcast drop it drops on Thursday right
yes every Thursday every Thursday if you
want to figure out what these two are
drinking I mean uh what their advice is
you can find out cocktail and Cocktails
so you get both yeah I just I'm a little
I saw on social media I don't see much
on social media but I was thumbing
through my insta what do you call that
the gram no you're right it's the insta
the green the Graham and there's a
little kid 10 years old yeah drinking
the mocktail
that you all taught him to make
money happier I think you're causing
juvenile delinquency
that's what I'm thinking it's probably
there's no alcohol it was probably
muddled strawberries no it was the one
it was like a float it had like ice
cream or something I mean we yeah we had
yeah
yeah listen you need something
I think you're causing problems
pop culture and money and hey we get we
get messages all the time that
six-year-old seven-year-olds love the
show and even like 80 year olds love
them teaching them to drink we got no
we're not
drink
it's not a show about drinking people
I'm just kidding I do have a drink of
the day and it's because it's happy hour
sometimes I have alcohol so check it out
it's always fun and funny because George
and Rachel are if anything they're fun
if anything they're always fun so be
sure to check it out I think somebody
wishes we talked about money a little
bit more and a little less fun sometimes
but we have a lot of it's kind of in the
title smart money
happy hour there's that yeah okay so I'm
just just holding you accountable to
that that's all open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Madison is in Des Moines Iowa hi Madison
how are you
hey good thanks for having me guys sure
what's up
um so my question is I have a camper
that I'm running out and making good
money on
um but we're living in a dumpy house and
we got a lot of debt that we need to
tackle so should I sell that camper and
make uh get like fifteen thousand
dollars back plus get rid of that loan
debt and put that on my current debt or
should I move my family into the camper
and
um kind of use that as our
uh use it as a way to decrease our
expenses okay I'm a little bit unclear
how you rent out campers for money
what's going on to explain that to me
yeah oh yeah there's some great uh
websites that you can go it's kind of
like an Airbnb oh so it's like a camper
Uber okay
that's right yeah so I just drop it off
to people and they rent it for a weekend
or something
my God what will they come up with next
okay I didn't know yeah I'm just
learning something okay so what is it
how much do you make on that I'm just
curious I'm gonna tell you to sell it
anyway but how much do you make on it
I've been making about a grand a week
which has been nice extra cash for us
what's it worth
the camper is worth 43 000. how much you
owe I owe 25
000 25 000.
every week you're making a thousand
dollars
every week that it's rented I would say
oh well no kidding how many weeks is it
rented
uh most weeks I probably at least three
weeks uh a month and is that is that
year round though Madison is that just
because of the summer
just because of the summer okay I have
been looking into uh so you're not
making fifty two thousand dollars a year
a thousand dollars a week you're making
twenty thousand dollars a year
yes okay all right that's helpful
because I was about to just have a
coronary over here about to go on a
camper business but anyway the um no
yeah sell it I listen you're not in a
position to be in the camper investment
Airbnb business you're broke
yeah yeah that's what you already knew I
just said how much debt do you guys have
Madison total
combined with me and my husband we have
about 140 000 in what um
uh we have a business that we started
and that's been doing really well but to
the startup cost for that was uh we have
about 15 000 left on that we have a
vehicle I have student loans
um how much you owe on the vehicle
the vehicle about 40 000.40 on the
student loans
45 000. okay and how much you guys make
a year
uh about 144 000 and then the and then
you owe 20 on the camper
25 on the camera that gets us to 140.
okay hey yeah yeah yeah and your
household income is what
144 000. and you're in a dumpy house
yeah we are renting because uh we moved
back from Florida weren't sure what to
do with the business but we really need
to have a place that we have the
business at home because it's so uh
inconvenient right now uh the house is
is not in the best shape not in the best
neighborhood you don't have two years
tax returns on the business though do
you
I don't have uh my tax returns the CPA
that I hired no I mean you haven't had
the business two years have you
I have it's in the third year right now
okay did you make enough in the two
years on your tax returns when you do
get them done to take them to the
mortgage company and get a mortgage for
a house
yes
okay
so if you sold the camper
and you tore Into the Dead and knocked
out the debt and then saved up a down
payment
and you sold a car you could be debt
free
um in less than a year and start talking
about buying a house
yes
we're at now yeah that sounds pretty
good
okay yeah Madison if I were you guys I
would just sell like sell whatever you
can sell the camper sell the car like
all that stuff you can re-buy later sell
both cats but it's like just get rid of
stuff and I mean obviously the student
loan in the business loan those are
still going to be around but knock those
two out and yeah and I think you guys
are gonna be in a totally different
position I think it's a good just mental
exercise for you guys just to get you've
been carrying around all this stuff
that's equated to carrying around debts
and just getting rid of some of it I
think it's going to bring you a lot of
Peace it's kind of a minimalism move for
you guys yeah and and yeah and and your
the thing is you're just entrepreneurial
and you see something shiny and you jump
on it
yeah that's how the camper thing
happened and then oh and then I could go
over and do this and I can do that and I
can do this and then all of a sudden
your life got real cluttered
yeah that's exactly right well the
camper we bought because we moved into
it and we were living in it for a while
and then we have three kids that didn't
work um so we decided the adventure was
over but now we're in the house and
that's not working either so well let's
let's have a one year to 18 month plan
to be 100 debt free with an emergency
fund and a down payment because you're
making really good money and get real
focused with a budget to do all this and
then sell everything in sight sell so
much stuff the kids think they're next
and really get in gear here and let's
get this stuff done Rachel's exactly
right that's what I would do because I
can see what the thing is that that with
the the cluttered approach the chaotic
approach that you've used to money so
far has kind of made you feel like you
can you're never going to get there and
we can see the numbers where you're
really going to get there very fast if
you take these dramatic moves yeah
absolutely and and I think it's just
gonna it's gonna bring you guys a level
of peace and control that you just
haven't had Madison I mean but of 140
80k is a camper in a car are right
that's what I'm saying so I'm like it's
amazing just like removing some of that
you know and then you put your life on
top of Medicine with three kids and you
guys are working you're starting a
business I mean you guys have a lot of
moving pieces in your life anyways and
so just simplifying and getting stuff
out I think is going to feel really
cleansing to you guys in more ways than
just the financial I think it's really
going to be helpful and then and then
working a plan and being intense on that
plan seeing progress and goals you guys
are really goal oriented so you're going
to start to feel that traction and yeah
I think you guys are going to kill it I
mean yeah I think you're gonna do great
yeah that's very good you really got the
potential if you just but you're gonna
have to make some pretty dramatic shifts
here in the short term to get your
long-term goals but I mean visualize
three years from now you're living in a
nice home with a 15-year fixed where the
payment's no more than a fourth of your
take-home pay your business is
continuing to grow and you've got no
debt other than that
I can breathe that in and that feels
like a better life and that's not that's
worth that's worth no camper no car yes
and that's not how to reach Madison that
dream for three years like that's that's
reality that's a completely doable yep
absolutely mathematically with Matthew
gave us it's doable but you guys got to
line up and get after it you got to bust
it and if you do that then this will
this will work for you good stuff good
stuff hey thank you for calling in
man I love people I just learned
something every day on this show today's
like make money rent out a camper well
I'm thinking should I 42 000 camper and
you're getting a thousand dollars a week
in 42 months you paid for the thing I
mean it's 42 weeks amazing world we live
in for the things but it doesn't stay
right I mean you rent out everything it
took me a minute to get to the bottom of
the business proforma but yeah okay
anyway this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Applause]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34
thousand customers who trust netsuite to
help make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsey
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today I'm Dave
Ramsey your host thanks for listening to
the Ramsay show we appreciate you if
you'd like to know more about what's
going on and how you fit into this Jake
go to ramseysolutions.com and click the
get started button we'll help you figure
out the best next step in your journey
and I help you along the way in the
whole process so thanks for hanging out
with us Josh is in Shreveport Louisiana
hey Josh welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey guys thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
so my question is my wife and I are
working through the baby steps right now
and uh around the first of the year we
should be starting baby steps four five
and six excellent I'm a high income
earner uh and so my question is can we
take I know we're supposed to do 15
towards retirement what if we only did
10 and took the other five percent and
helped get our mortgage out of the way
as well
don't how much what do you make what's
your high income about 500 000. good for
you what do you do
I'm a physician way to go man way to go
well obviously Josh you're a grown
person you're allowed to do whatever you
want to do
um you're just asking if we would do
that I think
yes sir okay so you certainly can do
that and will you end up broke if you do
that no no you have a paid for house and
a little less in retirement and then
you'll uh probably correct and start
doing more Investments when you don't
have a house payment I assume right
yes sir that's correct uh we're um right
now we have 600 000 in retirement
already yep
um not bad you know we'll yes sir we're
we're working at it how much is the
house how much do you have left on the
house
well about five hundred thousand okay
all right well here's the thing it the
it's a pretty simple thing it's just if
you uh uh do 10 instead of fifteen
percent the house is gonna be paid off a
little faster
and you're going to have a little less
in retirement if you do it our way you
have a little more in retirement and
it's going to take a little bit longer
to pay off the house but um you know
neither one of these are going to break
the bank I I would tell you that I've
I'm you know you're going to be okay
there's neither one of these are in the
stupid column like you're please don't
do that you're going to destroy your
life none of that is in this discussion
okay so this is just nuanced stuff so
you do you you need to do whatever you
feel is best for you I'm very
comfortable that you're going to get
both things done anyway
and and
um it's not and honestly I think you'd
be surprised if you actually put a
spreadsheet on this that it's not going
to make that much difference at the end
of the story say a 15-year uh timeline
time Horizon how much difference is your
net worth going to be one way or the
other it's not going to be much you're
not really gaining hardly anything so
I'm going to stick with our plan because
I've seen it work so many times I'm
really not going to stray from it but
I'll just say again a uh but because I
don't want to put out there that oh well
if you're high income earner this stuff
doesn't apply to you yes it does yeah
yes it does and um you know and if you
had a hundred thousand dollar mortgage
and you made a hundred thousand dollars
a year instead of making a half million
with a half million dollar mortgage I
would tell you exactly the same thing so
the nut it's still just ratios and so uh
you know you're going to be in debt X
number of years longer
my way maybe two years more something
like that
than you would your way so it's a
two-year differentiation that we're
discussing we're not even arguing about
but but no it doesn't change it you're
income doesn't change the principles so
um the other thing is this
yeah yeah that's what I would do I I
would do I would stay right with the
baby steps yeah but but but it's not
again I you're going to get to the end
you're gonna be fine as long as you stay
on either one of those tracks and you
don't go off into the La La Land and
start buying Bitcoin or some stupid butt
stuff or something then you're gonna be
just fine you know you're gonna be fine
good good call thank you for joining us
all right Christian is in Pittsburgh hey
Christian what's up
hi so I was calling call um I'm
currently working a career that I'm
pretty much burned out in and I don't
know how much longer I can do it
um so I was wondering if I should try
and stick it out to save up the money to
go back to school or if it would be
worth it to take a loan out in this case
what do you do
I'm a nurse a critical care nurse okay
how long have you been doing it
uh two and a half years
and what do you want to do
Aviation yeah commercial pilot
what got you into nursing
so when I was 14 I joined the fire
department and that turned into working
on the ambulance and then that kind of
um turn into nursing and doing critical
care and
Aviation X really has always been
something I've wanted to do but nursing
was just an easier path at the time
how much does it cost to to go through
that schooling to get your pilot's
license
it depends on the program that I do
anywhere from 50 to 100 000.
what are you making what state
um my fiance and I combined household is
120 000 a year you're not combined
you're not married what do you make wow
I make uh 60 000. we both make sixty
thousand
that's weird you're working Critical
Care 40 hours and you're only making 60
Grand in Pittsburgh
yep Pittsburgh has a lot of nursing
schools so they have very low it's a you
know supply and demand there's a huge
supply of nurses not
a ton of demand because they can get new
grads they come in Yeah we actually just
did a salary episode for the smart money
happy hour George and I did and we just
taped it yesterday and yeah we the
nursing yeah it was right around that's
the national average actually it's right
around there uh which is which was lower
than what I was incredible hair that's
not that's that's low for critical care
uh okay
um
no I'm not gonna tell you to go into
debt for anything ever I haven't in 35
years and we're not going to start today
with you okay now past that uh then what
do we do to live a proper life and Live
Your Dream right
um so you need 50 Grand and you need to
adjust where you're working because it's
not nursing that's driving you nuts it's
the location and the people and the
particular stress of critical care
that's driving you nuts
okay you didn't suddenly lose your heart
for healing you've had a heart for
healing for a decade or more
yeah you're not burnt out on healing are
there other positions Christian that
you're aware of in the nursing field
that you're like okay I could I could do
that for three more years or for two
more years while I say
yeah there are the problem is that I
don't meet the experience requirements
for that yet so like being a flight
nurse working on the helicopter was also
a dream of mine but they require five
years experience I'm only at three so I
need to do it for two more years who's
they
um that particular hospital that's not
an industry standard
um three to five years of the industry
standard for flight nursing
of experience critical care experience
you got three
so that's good yeah so I just wonder
yeah and you came out of the fire
department so you should know somebody
yeah the problem is all the services
near me
um due to their unions require five
years
um so it would have to move and
currently my fiance is under a contract
with her job that we can't move because
she took a sign on business it's kind of
where I'm yeah so I'm gonna make some
kind of an adjustment
because the adjustment that you're
talking about making is stupid don't do
it
okay you're going to go into debt to
become a pilot and it's going to take
you forever to start making a living
doing that because you're you're but get
you're going to start at the beginning
again I mean entry level and entry level
Pilots don't make spit
in today's world okay I mean you're
getting ready to take a pay cut and go
in debt for the opportunity no thank you
now do you want to go be a pilot sure
that's fine I got no issue with that if
that's what the game you want to play
but
um I I really think you have a heart for
healing and I don't know that you'll be
a nurse 10 years from now but I think
you easily got three or four more years
left in you you may just need to adjust
where you are and how you're doing it
and do you pick up a travel nursing gig
and double your income uh temporarily
and be gone a little bit from the fiance
and try to make some money and you know
refresh your spirit and refresh your
wallet to get ready to go work on this
but but dude you're going to spend 50 60
80 grand to go be a pilot and then
you're going to make less than you make
now
well that doesn't make any sense at all
okay and so we've got to have a better
plan than that that has some common
sense around it yes do what you love but
don't do what you love in a way that's
stupid that's always a bad plan and
people justify a lot of stupidity
because it's my passion and that's dumb
don't do that and you're not going to
you're not going to because you're
thinking about it we appreciate you
calling this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save up to 40 off everything site-wide
go to blinds.com for more information
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsey show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality
number one best-selling author and
co-host of the smart money Happy Hour
podcast on the Ramsay networks be sure
and check it out is my co-host today
also my daughter open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Jason is in Boise hi Jason welcome to
the Ramsey hi Rachel hi Dave how are you
better than we deserve sir how can we
help good I was wondering if you could
settle kind of a disagreement my wife
and I
um I think gazelle intends for about
five years now but I have a mortgage
still in a home equity line of credit we
need to pay off and I want to attack the
home equity line of credit
because of it it's freaking out because
of the interest like it's not a fixed
interest rate and my mortgage is a fixed
interest rate at like 2.75 and we've got
that paid down
about down about thirty thousand dollars
right what do you owe on the home equity
line
180. good Lord
yeah I know yeah it was uh it was a we
bought a home about what's your
household income
uh about ninety thousand uh you need to
refinance and get you a new First
Mortgage
okay that was my next question this is
what the goats I want to pay off the
home mortgage refinance and then get it
locked in yeah I hate to lose the two
percent but it's only on 30k of 210 so
mathematically it doesn't come out to be
much so and you get rid of the massive
mess on the other side put it on a
15-year fixed and then that becomes a
maybe step six and you can chill and
start working your baby steps four five
six because I assume you have your
emergency fund done we do and we also my
next I was wondering if you we own a
business a small business and I was
wondering if we should sell it and then
be totally debt free
I if we sold it it's not your primary
source of income
yes it is it is how much do you sell it
for
yeah
um we were asking 330 for it
so it's already up percent
what's that it's already up for sale
no it's not yet no we're not asking
anything yet okay not at not asking that
but that doing the math to be debt free
and after paying a capital gains tax and
then a broker I was wondering
um I would not sell it just to pay off
the house I mean if this is are you done
with this business I'm ready to move on
another chapter of your life that's a
whole different discussion than the
mortgage discussion
and well we have been talking about
we've been running this business for
almost five years now and I just thought
well if we rent for five years or done
built up the brand and then we sold it
then we can be why not run it for 50
years and make money on it
yeah that's what my wife said you were
going to say well I mean no I'm just
asking if you don't if you hate it and
you want to sell it because you hate
going down there every day that's a
career question
okay but there's not a thing that says
you have to sell a business when it's
built up we're not selling this one it's
going to the kids
okay yeah because we do we have to put a
lot of hard work into it you enjoy it
Jason do you guys you guys
we absolutely do it's just sometimes it
is a little tough with uh
the the inflation and stuff everybody's
going through it and I know that but and
we have been dealing with since we're
the small business we're dealing with
kids not wanting to work and so we're
working it most the time but we do enjoy
beating that was part of opening the
business was to be together all the time
and not be apart from each other okay
yeah I I think you need to assess that
separately from the debt issue
okay do we want to be running this
business or do we need to make some
changes so that we want to keep running
the business or do we want to sell the
business any of those are fine there's
no wrong answer there I would not tell
you you need to sell that to get rid of
their stupid home equity loan no that's
not a statement you're going to get here
um I'm sorry your wife won the argument
but you need to get a new Mortgage and
pay off the home equity loan okay
okay call Churchill Mortgage they'll
help you get that refinanced and
um the two percent is horrible to get
rid of but again it's a very small
amount of your loan and the big amount
of your loan is an angry monster loan
and it's gonna eat you
don't let it do that and he could feel
it couldn't he oh yeah yeah like this
thing's bad his wife can feel it I
wouldn't yeah yeah make it consistent
know what you're getting predictable and
you guys just put in baby step six yeah
that's great there is a
there's a good part of money that's
um you should attempt to approach boring
you want to be have a boring automatic
kind of thing going on with your money
and so if your money is super exciting
all the time uh that probably means
you're taking a lot of risk and there's
a lot of chaos going on and so generally
speaking the people and and I don't mind
the excitement I'm an entrepreneurial
type but from a just from a process
standpoint you should you should be
pretty calm the data tells us that the
calm steady people are the ones that
have more money yeah they're the ones
that end up millionaires the consent
it's the consistency
the tortoise not the hair yeah and so if
there's any time you approach chaos or
versus order order is better you know
and it's just like you know this because
the other is just flailing and it's
desperation and there's this there's a
lot anxiety around it and all this and
you don't want to get there you don't
want to get there Travis is in Phoenix
hi Travis how are you
good how are you doing this afternoon
better than I deserve what's up
uh we're gonna get some advice on how to
pay off two new vehicle notes that my
wife and I just did in March good Lord
uh why did you do that
because we make good money and we like
to we don't make good enough money pay
cash for those cars
I should have but I did not you have the
cash
we do have about 350 in the bank right
now write a check and pay off your cars
that was my question we have a CD come
and do in two weeks that could pay those
off and I wasn't sure if we should just
cash out the CD I've never met anybody
that got rich borrowing on their cars
and investing in CDs
okay definitely makes sense so that was
my question you know instead of putting
money into savings every month we Bank
about five to six thousand a month I was
wondering if we should save a couple
months pay off one save a couple months
pay off the other or just lump it with
the CD in two weeks you shouldn't have
done this unless you wrote a check to
buy them
quit buying things unless you pay for
them
that's what rich people do they pay for
things you make a lot of money but it's
new to you
have this big piles of cash is fairly
within the last eight or nine years yeah
yeah this is not like something you've
done for 25 years and so you're still
trying to get used to these number of
zeros that are in your life emotionally
and some so sometimes it feels like well
maybe I need to do that and I wonder
what's sophisticated and don't be
sophisticated just pay for crap and if
you if you do that you'll always have
your power your most powerful wealth
building tool at your disposal which is
your income Thank God Travis I mean you
guys are doing an incredible job got a
lot of money so it's like just use it
yeah
borrowed to buy two new cars and I'm
broke that was even been worse but at
least you got the money in the bank and
you can just write a check and you're
free and you can go all those dumb I
should have done that now I got rid of
the dumb now I just got the cars okay
gonna feel good Travis a little less
dumb okay there you go this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lump sum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call 8442
Ramsey or go to
yrefi.com Ramsay
[Music]
[Applause]
well there's some cool stuff going on
around Ramsey right now tomorrow
for most of you that will be August the
9th on Wednesday Jade warshaw will be
doing a free webinar on budgeting if you
want to sign up for Jade teaching you
how to use the every dollar app and a
whole budgeting seminar is completely
free
just go to everydollar.com
budgeting budgeting
that'll get you signed up Rachel is
going to be doing one of those teaching
about how to do an irregular income or
how to do budgeting in of any kind and
go through the whole process of walking
the baby steps with the new Financial
roadmap that's part of the every dollar
uh app and that is at if you want to
sign up for hers that's going to be the
15th of August yeah these are these are
really great too because there's a lot
of q a it's a lot of interactive and if
you feel like you're alone in the stress
of budgeting or even the idea of oh my
gosh how do I even start this I just I
feel overwhelmed with my money that's
how majority of people feel so you are
normal and this is a place in a space
that we're creating for you guys just to
come in and ask her questions and talk
through hey how do you take this
emotional thing that is really difficult
and actually put something into practice
that you can have and honestly even with
the app like every dollar you use every
day to help you in control of your money
first time he drove a car it was awkward
first time you do a budget it's awkward
I don't care if you've got a PhD in
finance learning to do a budget is
awkward it feels weird it's a new skill
and it takes a little bit so Rachel's
webinar on the 15th will be at
everydollar.com slash webinar if you
want to sign up for that so slash
budgeting for Jades on the 9th slash
webinar for Rachel on the 15th and we'll
be having one with George sometime after
that we'll let you know of course so the
the three Ramsay personalities that deal
with money other than me are going to be
doing these uh every dollar budgeting
webinars for a couple of weeks here to
try to get you guys started going into
the fall kids are going back to school
it's time to get your crap together now
people time to get lined up and we'll
show you how it feels good can I say
that as a mom with the kids going back
to school like like one time we're
working out we're eating better now kids
are on a schedule life is like you just
get back in a routine after the summer
fog and so like this is the time to do
it like things are shaping up in your
life and you know the schedules it's a
real thing so make money part of that
too in this and this part of the year
because it's a great it's the second New
Year we call it all the time absolutely
all right Paul is in Springfield hey
Paul welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey how you guys doing today better than
we deserve what's up
um so I'd be honestly listening to a lot
of your podcasts about Building Wealth
and um this is something I've been
working on for
I'd say almost 10 years now I'm 31. good
for you I'm sorry thank you
um I started investing heavily into real
estate because that's what my father did
and I saw the value in that of passive
income for retirement
um
I started a new job a couple years ago
and started making life-changing money
just a lot more money so I started
getting um
a financial advisor to make sure I don't
spend the money stupidly or just to
start investing in spreading my
investments a little bit more broadly
and you know obviously I want to keep
investing in things and keep growing
this wealth smartly but I was just kind
of looking for what your advice of you
what you think may be the next best
steps would be
well I think you're going to be fine uh
if you'll uh behave in a couple of areas
the reason I think you're going to be
fine is the reason most people don't
succeed with money is they just don't
bother to pay attention and you've been
paying close attention for a decade
which is very important and so I'm
guessing that you probably made some
really good strides so this wonderful
money you're making how much do you make
um well last year I made 540 000.
um this year I'm already I'm 100
commission based job
um so right now I'm at I think 300 000
so I'll probably I'm guessing I'm gonna
make close to five again this year
um I have so in total I'm sorry I
thought you said 140 000 and then you
said 500 000 which is it
no and so I made I'm gonna make about
another 150 000 I think this year so I
think I'll be at 500 000 again for the
year
I think I'll be making 500k again this
year so last year you made 500 000 this
year you're on like five hundred
thousand dollars
probably yes
that's fine I'm just trying to get a
journal I couldn't I misunderstood what
you said earlier okay good wonderful
congratulations that's just a Fab you're
right that's that's sick money it's
wonderful I love it for you you're
obviously doing something you're
obviously doing some good so here's what
here's a couple of rules I've discovered
in 30 years of working with wealthy
people okay number one almost no one
statistically becomes a millionaire from
an inheritance so that's all just
mythology and bullcrap okay and we've
done the largest study of millionaires
ever done in North America 10 167 of
them 89 of them did not become
millionaires because of inherited money
so you're not that unusual as you become
a millionaire number two millionaires do
not do super fancy weird extremely risky
things and keep their money they usually
lose everything if they do so the
millionaires that we have studied are
fair really boring they put money in
things they understand and like for me I
buy growth stock type Mutual Funds
growth growth and income aggressive
growth International that kind of thing
and I buy real estate that I pay cash
for like you I grew up in a real estate
family mom and dad were in the business
and so I've Loved real estate I got my
real estate license when I turned 18
years old I love real estate I've got
buku's a real estate several hundred
million dollars worth but I pay cash for
it and I don't have any debt and all
cash flows like a bandit and I don't
have any of it that causes me super
stress because of that so
um you know but that's that's how I live
and my life is great because of that so
I would tell you to invest in things you
understand and you're comfortable with
obviously real estate is that
people who like real estate people who
like real estate often take on a whole
lot more debt than I think they should
right so yeah like I I haven't been
buying for cash per se and if I do buy
for cash it's because it's a it's a
foreclosure you know I'm gonna renovate
it and the goal is obviously to buy it
at the right price point it always is
over invest and then and then refinance
it putting 20 down and using the the
passive income of the rents to pay
myself back or I have enough equity let
me stop you for a second there is no
passive income from rents if you've been
dealing with renters you've figured out
it ain't passive
well yeah it depends on how good you are
at screening no it's not passive I've
been doing it for 40 years dealing with
renters commercial or residential is not
passive that's Tick Tock mythology okay
the term no the real world is it's
active you're active you have to real
estate has the highest hassle factor of
just about any investment you do but it
has one of the higher returns so anyway
you called to ask what what I think you
should do I think you should use this
fabulous income to clear off all this
stupid debt you've got on this real
estate and you're going to have a much
higher trajectory in your wealth growth
long term short term it's going to slow
you down but long term when you have no
debt on this portfolio and the piece
that goes with that and this cash flow
that's going to go with it you're going
to buy a lot more real estate and pay
cash for it that's how I've got several
hundred million dollars worth I don't
have any rents that go to
anything except buying more stuff
I don't have any no payments yeah but
but you you hit on this earlier and I
think it's true when you get into the
real estate game majority of people they
have to go to the bank right like they
like when they're playing this game and
the majority of them arched in the
business 10 years later yeah because
they think it's passive it's not yeah
and they think there's no risk in the
debt and there's a lot of risk in that
debt yes and so it's worth going slow
the you know the the phrase you coined
of moving at the speed of cash and
everything you do including real estate
but that is a slower Pace than again
what you're going to see on your Tick
Tock or Instagram reels of people doing
real estate so when I when I was in my
20s I started buying real estate and I
was in a Real Estate Investors club that
followed all the crap like we do on Tick
Tock now while there's nothing down real
estate or stay in leverage crap okay and
the guys that were in that club there
were several people that had millions of
dollars of net worth in that club a
hundred percent of them now 30 years
later are broke and out of the business
oh or they paid off their debts and they
have paid for Real Estate there's three
of them that I know of are still
standing and they all paid it off and
became debt free the rest of them that
tried to continue to play The Leverage
game they got hammered in one of the
downturns or another and they're gone
they're out of business this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
here I'm a huge fan of both meditation
and prayer and good mental health
includes slowing down gaining control of
your thoughts and plugging into
something bigger than you and Halo makes
it easy to start a daily practice of
meditation prayer and finding peace
Hollow is the number one Bible app in
the world and you can tailor content
towards your faith tradition from
scripture readings and prayers to
meditation and journaling hallow makes
it easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com Ramsay today to get three
months of hallow for free that's
hollow.com Ramsay
thank you
[Music]
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality is my
co-host today well Rachel all these
years of hard work have paid off
I finally made it
what happened
I'm on the Babylon B podcast you're
doing it it's dropped today the guys
were here the other day and we taped it
and so I have arrived well they love you
on all the memes well I love they love
me because I get them clicks is what
they love me for we had a great lunch
together they're smart guys they are
funny as crud and um we've been
following the bee since it started back
in the day yeah and uh uh and they've
used me for is it a satire podcast
no you don't need me doing humor um it
would be weird but yeah no I mean not
that you know we we had fun though
they're really good guys they're really
smart guys and so it's official I have
arrived well done yeah I'll I'll be
getting emails from all my old friends
that are huge Babylon B podcast fans
don't love it hey Dave you really did it
man you broke through so there you go I
wonder what my podcast would be that I'd
be like I've made it
I have a list there was a little bit of
sarcasm in there but not much I was
hinting a little bit I know but it's um
but that plays into their brand
there we go the first the first time I
was on the Today show I got off and went
to the Green Room this was a thousand
years ago and this lady was in The Green
Room crying
because she had just done her appearance
and she had for 21 years it was her goal
to be on the Today Show and I just kind
of walked in and did it and I didn't
know it was supposed to be a goal for 21
years and so I'm like that's weird this
is your 21-year goal for a three-minute
hit on The Today Show some people work
hard towards things I get it I get it
but it was just like this is your
Pinnacle really but yeah okay I mean I
thought you'd say that about my Pinnacle
I gotta think of mine yeah what was
yours I'll come back to it mine could
have been Sally Jesse Raphael you'll
remember her with the red glasses yeah
that could have been a breakthrough or
the time I argued by the time I argued
with Oprah that might have been when I
peaked yeah that was back when I peaked
Joe hey Dr John deloney has a brand new
book coming out he has not peaked he is
a Skyrocket shooting to the Moon baby
I'm just saying and this book is selling
like crazy
man what a success thank you guys we
appreciate your response to this it is a
fabulous book it's called a building
a non-anxious life the six daily choices
that you make to get anxiety lowered
because anxiety is telling you something
else is wrong so you fix the six things
that are wrong the anxiety goes down
ta-da just like that and so uh very
tough to do but really good book it
actually pubs uh October 3rd but it's in
pre-sale right now and a whole bunch of
you have taken advantage of the deal
where we're selling the book for twenty
dollars and throwing in seventy five
dollars worth of goodies we're bribing
you to buy it early because it helps us
with the marketing because all the sales
up until Pub day count the first week
towards the bestseller list so thank you
it helps us and uh we appreciate that we
appreciate you guys stepping up and
getting this instant access to his
newest talk smoke fire and freedom you
also get the ebook the audio book all of
this and the book itself for seventy
five dollars we'll ship it all to you
except the talk
the what not for 75 I'm sorry it's 75
worth of stuff for 20 bucks yes twenty
dollars that's the deal serious deal
really I mean you can't even the paper
cost has gone up 40 this year people
hello so anyway and we still got the
book at 20 bucks so ramseysolutions.com
you can pre-order the new book
ah man anxiety you got to get rid of
building a non-anxious it's Tyler
Tyler's with us Tyler's in Tampa Florida
hi Tyler welcome to the Ramsay show
hi Dave thank you for taking my call
it's an honor to speak with you you too
what's up
so I have a question
um my wife and I have been paying off
debt for about the last year and a half
now we've been able to pay off about 60
000 out of a hundred
and um I actually didn't know about uh
the baby steps until about six months
ago so at the beginning we were kind of
Davis
um I guess you could say and now we're
trying to get a little more uh gazelle
intense with it
um we've been doing pretty well with
following a budget
and um
I just am struggling with certain
expenses
um related to like family events I don't
get together with my family very often
we have a wedding coming up that we're
going to
uh and then I just found out from my
sister that um for her 40th birthday she
wants us to fly out to California and um
spend a weekend with her at a resort
and uh it's gonna it's gonna cost us a
little over a thousand dollars for me to
go do that um I'm having a hard time
deciding whether or not that's a good
way to go we have I have just my student
loans left to pay off about 40 000
um I was really hoping to knock that out
we've been able to increase our income
um so I've been hoping to be able to do
that in the next few months and I'm just
not sure whether or not that's a good
idea you know I thought I'd get your
advice
yeah I mean Tyler the I mean the reality
is we always say the the deeper you
sacrifice the more money that's on the
debt obviously the faster it's going to
be paid off but life is going to be
intertwined throughout that and that's
when you and your wife have to kind of
make the call yourselves and to say okay
what are things going on that we feel
like we want to be a part of
uh with our family what are things that
we feel like gosh we do but then we also
are like we could do something else at a
later date because we want this mess
cleaned up so again it goes back to
because when we get the we get this type
of call the time of like yeah we have a
you know my brother is getting married
across the country what do we do
um so I mean again it's one of those
things that you guys have to decide is
this going to this is going to slow us
down in our debt payoff but is it worth
it for what we're doing with our family
so I mean the problem Tyler
is this
every time you let one of these things
in
you not only lose the money
towards your get out of that plan but
you lose
10x
the emotional momentum
because your lack of commitment
to the process your lack of intensity to
the idea of getting out of debt is
chipped away at and finally it just
doesn't matter and you stay in debt and
you're a freaking normal broke American
that goes to his sister's 40th birthday
on a freaking airplane
and that's what happens yeah and uh you
know all of a sudden you just look up
and you just got fat financially and and
it's one hamburger at a time you know
and so it's not the thousand dollars
it's the lack of you guys being dialed
in and going game on I got one plan for
a short period of time I'm gonna take no
prisoners nothing's going on this
complete emotional sellout and focus to
winning the Super Bowl is the only way
you win the Super Bowl no one half butts
their way into the Super Bowl
and that's what you got to get that's
what the what you got to decide it's the
emotional problem the math really isn't
the problem it's this is but it's this
amen and then well and then yeah and
then when then we're going I'm kind of
tired I think I'll go out to eat well
why call the wambulance get your butt in
gear and get out of debt you know and
that's that's the kind of thing that's
the internal self-talk that has to
change you've got to get this commitment
up and that's the problem and it's not
I'm not mad at your sister and but you
you know broke people that are forty
thousand dollars in debt on stupid but
student loans shouldn't be getting on an
airplane to go to somebody's birthday
party think about it man that's just a
dumb statement
he is I know but I feel Tyler and like I
get it but I'm telling you this is this
is what yes
I'm saying Tyler that's how you talk to
yourself
that's how you talk to yourself you got
to go I'm too stinking broke to go up
there because I'm in student loan debt
and I can't do this right now but that's
the truth right but it's not me yelling
at Tyler I'm just saying this is the way
you have to you have to shift your brain
into this gear where you're just going
enough I'm not living this way anymore
but and the hard thing is though is that
life now 40th birthday it's more
flippant than like a wedding or a
funeral like there are life events that
occur listen if you have to be there get
your butt in your car and drive up there
then don't talk to me about buying an
airplane ticket when you're broke
with the Kmart used tent that we bought
at Walmart or at a garage sale and we're
peddling our bicycle over there that's
your get out of yeah no
Chase man no and Tyler that that I'm not
yelling at you I'm yelling for you okay
I want you to get this in your head and
this is how you're talking to yourself
and don't talk to your wife this way
either talk to yourself this way we're
getting out of debt we got to pay a
price to win nobody wins without paying
a price
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
Rachel Cruz Ramsay personality number
one best-selling author and co-host of
the smart money happy hour with George
Campbell the my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five
so guys the thing that you're always
going to hear from us is
there's very few times on this show that
we're actually going to be fussing at
you we'll be fussing with you
and if we call you stupid or call what
you're doing stupid rather we won't call
you stupid we might call what you did
stupid but it's because we know what
stupid looks like we've done it I've
done it more than even Rachel Rachel
grew up in a household where I'd quit
doing stupid by the time she was born
and came along I had gone broke but I
know what stupid looks like and we have
figured out that personal finance is 80
Behavior it's only 20 percent head
knowledge
and you've got to study
and think about this money stuff through
the lens of behavior modification
it's not a math problem
so how do I modify my behavior well I
have to commit to and my friend James
Clear in this Mammoth book that he did
called Atomic habits I have to change my
identity I am no longer a person
who makes stupid but immature impulsive
financial decisions and then looks in
the mirror and wonders why I'm broke
I'm no longer that guy I instead am very
careful and very slow and one of the
things we'll help you do here
occasionally and you don't even know
we're doing it but it were very
intentional about it is we want you to
have a new identity when you get off the
call
and that guy
doesn't think of himself as a broke
person with forty thousand dollars in
student loan debt but when you have no
money and forty thousand dollars in
student loan debt you need to identify
yourself as a broke person because you
are a broke person broke people don't do
some things that people that aren't
broke can do
and there and you quit doing those
things so that you aren't broke people
anymore and so if you are a doctor and
you make 250 000 a year and you owe a
hundred and ten thousand dollars on your
BMW and 450 000 on your medical school
student loan debt you are a broke but
doctor
you need to re-identify
and go this is who I am and I want to
change that identity because then you
quit doing rich people stuff while
you're broke because when you do
Broast God so you just have to stop you
have to stop and uh you know it that's
when I went bankrupt and lost everything
because of my stupidity I had to reset
and go guess what
the stuff you believed about money
borrowing all you can getting your
credit card points doing anything you
want to do because I make good money
and everybody's got a different
different definition about what good
money is right I had to re-identify and
go no you're stupid you need to stop
being stupid and I think what's hard is
we've lived in a world in a culture
where you know because of the Avenue of
debt you accumulate not just stuff and
but even if you have a good income like
you're saying the doctor whoever I'm
making good money I have the stuff and
it's like the part of the debts of the
uh what I own minus what I owe doesn't
come as an equation it's just you stay
at that top you know sphere emotionally
instead of looking at the reality of the
numbers so how do you modify Behavior
you first identify reality of where I am
and I'm going to reset my identity and I
don't want to be that person anymore
yeah so I'm going to quit being that you
know I'm gonna do the things I'm going
to take the steps I'm going to make the
sacrifices so that I don't do that and
I've used the example on this on the air
many times here uh and the point that
the people in the booth are sick of it
but during covid we were working the
leadership team trying to keep this
place open and I figured out later that
how I deal with high stress scenarios is
I eat
a lot
I ate every donut in a 50 mile radius I
got donuts I was already overweight and
when I get to covet I went into donut
mode and I got so freaking fat it was
ridiculous I looked in the mirror this
round head looked like a basketball it
was crazy and I'm like this has gotta
you know you're you're a donut eating
fat boy you need to stop this
and that's how you stop it you know you
look at it and you go this is the
reality you have to stop doing this or
you're gonna explode
like the kid on Willy Wonka I mean it's
just awful you know you have to stop it
you have to stop it and so you know no
more donuts and the other day we had the
grandkid birthday with the donuts and
papa Dave made made a big deal about he
was going to steal one of the kids
Donuts but he didn't touch a donut do it
no more Donuts
I'm completely cold turkey on the
freaking donuts and uh you know I
dropped 40 42 pounds because I needed to
hello you know I mean and that's the
thing everybody has something like that
it's a behavior change it wasn't that I
intellectually and analyzed caloric
intake good Lord no I had to stop it
you know and that this is what we all
have to do I'm no different than anybody
else and that is my point and so guys
this is how money works
it's not a math problem it's a you
problem yep and when you get that man
you got the Ramsay thing down and then
you're gonna go in and this is how we've
talked and cajoled and motivated and
listened and praised and lifted more
people through their debt Journeys into
millionaire status than any other entity
on the planet
the Ramsey Solutions grew past
millions of people have completely
changed their lives financially because
of us on the radio doing what we're
doing right now us on the podcast doing
us on the stage
right now just telling you how to go be
a hero you're the solution go be the
hero it's up to you yes and so to the
caller earlier
it's up to him like right like if you
continue to just be that in and out
scenario like you're saying that's what
that's the result you're gonna get but
you decide that you have to make those
choices it's up to you and if you choose
hey I'm actually gonna go scorched Earth
I'm done because the reality is I am
broke I can't go do these fun things
that I want to do I don't have the money
you're making that choice to later then
actually have the money yes to do
anything you want yes you live like no
one else so that later you can live and
give like no one else you'll never be in
a position again that you have to choose
between your groceries and the broke
single mom in front of you whose third
credit card was denied and you want to
buy her groceries but you can't because
you can't even barely buy yours
and you don't ever want to be like that
again you always want to be the guy the
gal in line behind it goes hey I got
that and this why because I paid a price
I gave up the resort 40th birthday party
and I paid a price
to do the thing so that I can do
anything then and that's how this works
there's not a there's not a middle
ground well I sort of kind it doesn't
work you're either going to be just
sloppy and disorganized and in this
country you can have a really good life
with a fair amount of stress and be
deeply in debt and have a your standard
of living is ridiculous and you make 120
000 a year you're broke but you have an
incredible life you travel you can buy
cars you can do a lot of stuff that on
the surface looks like you've got it all
going on and you can live a stinking
life of rich people in any other country
for sure and be broke as broke and make
it all the way through to retirement and
go gosh I hope the government which is
well known for its ability to handle
money will take care of me
and and or you can decide I'm going to
be autonomous
and I don't really care what you think
about what I drive I don't really care
what you think about my vacation I don't
really care what you think about
anything I'm as for me and my house
we're going to get our crap together you
can make that decision and when you do
it changes everything it changes
everything not just financially though
as I'm like the underneath the surface
you guys when you live the first example
of that I'm like that is full of stress
and anxiety and pain and tension there's
so much just like you can't even breathe
yeah you got everything but you're
barely hanging on by a string one thing
that goes wrong the entire house Falls
versus the ladder and saying you know
what I'm actually going to build a life
yes all based on me and not all the
other facts you know the other industry
standards it's Botox Financial it's fake
you know it's fake it's a facade it's
more like filler Financial Botox just
plastic surgery Financial whatever right
it's like going to Universal and they
got this beautiful house only when you
walk through the back door there's
nothing there it's just a facade for the
camera and people live their lives that
way this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey it's Rachel Cruz co-host on the
Ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free scream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com set free screen we'd
love for you to come to Nashville and
tell Dave your story that's
ramsesolutions.com debt free screen
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Rachel Cruz
Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author and co-host for the
smart money happy hour uh podcast on the
Ramsay Network be sure and check it out
she's my co-host today open phones here
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five
Fox news reporting Americans are
increasingly turning to their credit
cards to cover everyday expenses with
debt surpassing
one trillion dollars for the first time
at the end of June according to the New
York Federal Reserve report published
today
in the three-month period from April to
June total credit card debt surged to
1.03 trillion dollars an increase of 45
billion or 4.6 percent from the previous
quarter it marks the highest level ever
on record in the FED dating back all the
way to 2003. the rise in credit card
usage and debt is particularly
concerning because interest rates are
astronomically high right now all horse
crap credit card interest rates have
always been astronomical High I've been
doing this show for 35 years they've
been 18 to 28 percent the whole time
I've been on the air no one thinks any
of that's low that's dumber than a rock
all right the average credit card annual
percentage rate or APR hit a record of
20.33 now according to bank rate and
that goes back to
1985. the previous record was 19 in July
of 91. say there's my arrest my point I
came on the air in 1994 or 1992 I'm
sorry and so yeah the interest rates
have always been at the screw you level
on credit cards okay let's just be
straight if people are carrying debt to
compensate for steeper prices they could
end up paying more items in the long run
for instance if you no kidding if you
owe five thousand dollars and you pay 28
on it it's going to be a lot of money we
don't need an article to figure that one
out one trillion dollars in credit card
debt is staggering well yeah that's true
guys
guys this is the dumbest thing I've seen
I don't know when
long does it take people to figure out
that these pieces of plastic called
credit cards are not there for you
how long does it take to figure out that
oh here's Bank of America Let's do an
on-air plastic surgery right now we're
just going to start chopping up carts
Bank of America that's two good things
to get rid of credit card and Bank of
America both stupid here's another
Platinum Bank of America we'll get rid
of that one too chase chase this okay
here's Home Depot they take cash by the
way you don't need this Countrywide
they're broke okay oh my God there's
another Bank of America we must collect
Bank of America old cards around here
these people uh just time to stop it is
time for a blastectomy America a
trillion
dollars in credit card debt I'm getting
airline miles no you're not you're in
debt
you're in debt a trillion dollars when
you do it with the student loans we call
it an epic pandemic crisis when we do it
with credit cards it's on the third page
of Fox's website it's a trillion dollars
of you buying crap you can't afford with
money you don't have to impress people
you don't even really like maybe you
should stop that
I don't know we've been doing this for
30 years how do you feel like we're not
getting anywhere
in progress It's not really showing up
Dave not really sure we're not really
moving the needle on America because
what I think has happened is I think
it's two things I think the the credit
card the game is a very real thing and
people say well if I'm gonna buy gas
might as well put it on my credit card
so I can get cash back if I'm going to
be buying this anyways might as well put
it on the credit card to get the airline
miles but it's kind of a Dr Phil thing
so how's that working it's living in
that cycle and then there's a there's a
real truth that people are using those
to pay for for food and to pay no no no
no no no no no no no yes they have the
money for food they're using these
because they don't want to cut off
Netflix
they're using these because they want to
go on vacation and they're broke that's
why they're using them it's the same
reason they've always been using them
you don't you cannot make an economic
case that people are actually have to
have a credit card for survival today
that's just not true it's not they in
their brains they keep saying
mathematical when you look at when you
look at their budget and you look at
what's going on and what they make and
what I mean everything in it it is it
what's hard is I'm like the math it is
tight it is hard but what happens is is
the standard of living that we're all
expected to live causes these things to
have to be a necessity in order to live
that standard of living and so to cut
to cut that well that means the average
American's living as stupid as their own
Congress is living well that they just
keep spending and spending and spending
like there's no tomorrow like there's no
Reckoning for this level of debt you
keep running up you got a trillion
dollars yeah 1.7 trillion in student
loan debt you got to now have a trillion
in credit card debt and then you can't
figure out why the average American
can't seem to get ahead well I think I
figured it out there's giving it all the
stinking Banks
that's why they got no money you work
your butt off your whole life and you
give all your money into a stupid Bank
and that's why you got no money it's not
a real hard formula no and I think that
and I think the perspective has to be
and the mindset shift has to be that if
you are someone listening and you're
like yeah I know but we're paycheck to
like we're we're not like doing
extravagant stuff we're just making the
it we're just living life and and so the
no debt philosophy even with credit
cards even with credit cards is to say
okay what like have a pretend scenario
pretend budget where you said we cannot
borrow anything we have to use the money
that hits our accounts yeah then you
that's how you build your life you're
right but what happens is is we build
our life around and then you refuse to
change it to adjust for the variables
and that's what's hard with the student
loan payments coming back in October
there's gonna be a rather huge expense
in the budget act like we're surprised
student loans came back hey Christmas is
always in December they don't move it
and the student loans are coming in
October we've been telling you this so
I'm just saying there's a there's going
to be a a level of pain that a lot of
people are going to start to feel even
more in the next few months you know
what these are these are plastic denial
yeah yeah I'm in denial that I have to
deal with my crap yes and so I'm gonna
put it on a credit card and act like
nothing changed well stuff changed Bubba
yep and these people this is not
sophisticated this is straight up stupid
these companies are screwing you and
you're signing up for the trip you're
asking for it and you're getting
hammered at 18 to 28 and you wonder why
you make a hundred thousand dollars a
year and have no money because you
signed up for a stupid trip on the
stupid cruise and it's called the
plastic Cruise it's out of control you
guys they have lulled you to sleep
they've made you believe you have to
have one of these stupid things to exist
don't leave home without it well guess
what Daniel Boone left home without it
he made it okay okay all right you can
make it without these stupid things get
you a debit card pay cash for it get
control of your life get some autonomy
from these Banks they own your butt and
you gave them the deed don't give them
the deed to your butt they own you this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
thank you for joining us America we
appreciate you being here this is the
Ramsey Show I'm your host Dave Ramsey
Rachel Cruz is my co-host today hey if
you want to help us out we would
appreciate it
you are our marketing budget yep you uh
if you'll follow the show click follow
click subscribe whether you're youtubing
or you're podcasting or if you're
listening on talk radio tell people
where you listen spread the word your
local talk radio station there's 680
stations carrying the show out there
right now if you're watching on TBN tell
people that wherever you're catching us
just let share about it I'll leave a
five star review click a follow click a
subscribe every time you do that it
helps us a bunch and we know you're
doing it and we know there's a bunch of
new people because you're doing that
thank you the other day we hit number 12
in the world on Apple podcast there's
4.2 million podcasts on Apple and we're
number 12. because of you guys and
that's important because they put them
up there in two rows of six so we barely
make the corner number 13 you don't see
it you see number 12 over there and it
helps us because people will listen that
way that never listened before and they
just never know what they're going to
get when they listen here so I'll
probably get hope get some hope and some
instruction and some aspiration and some
motivation and all that kind of stuff so
check it out hey speaking of hope uh Dr
John deloney has a new book out called
building a non-anxious life he's one of
our Ramsay personalities here he's got a
great podcast and he's on the this show
quite often as a co-host as well the
book is uh twenty dollars on how to get
rid of your anxiety really is what it
amounts to how do you build a life that
doesn't eliminate anxiety but lowers it
greatly and uh well you kind of get your
arms around it literally so it's twenty
dollars the book comes out October the
3rd we're in pre-sale right now so you
can get the book for 20 bucks and
because it's in pre-sale if you buy it
now we will give you an extra 75 dollars
in bonus items including the e-book and
the audiobook including one of his talks
uh that he did recently that is very
good so be sure you check this out get
it all at ramseysolutions.com store Dr
John deloney's new book building a
non-anxious life Alex is next Alex is in
Boston hey Alex what's up
hi David Rachel thanks for taking my
call our pleasure how can we help
great well Dave I've heard you uh well
let me start I'm 38 my fiance is 32
we're getting married in two months from
now congratulations
thank you so much uh and I've heard you
give kind of a rundown uh with some
callers on their uh assessing their
finances and their ability to afford a
home which we'd like to do hopefully in
the next say 12 to 18 months or so right
good plan
great so I guess I have been unknowingly
uh kind of working your steps for a
while now I've lived kind of like a grad
student for the last 10 years since
taking my first job and uh
kind of slowly getting my fiance on
board with living below means and less
online ordering and kind of getting a
handle on our finances
um and so yeah I I'd like to kind of
just get your thoughts on our Readiness
within that time frame
okay so I mean really it's gonna depend
on where you guys are you know debt wise
savings wise
um and what houses are in the area that
you guys can afford so when you guys get
married and everything is combined how
much debt will you guys have
so we have no debt no student loan debt
uh we would have some potential debt if
uh if my wife was too uh not work at her
job then her car payment would become
her own
um but that's our only yeah no that's
not how that works
do they furnish her a car or do they
give her a car allowance
they give her a car allowance okay she
has car debt
because if you lose the job you're in
cardet the car isn't her name the debt
isn't her name
she's got card debt you got the car
allowance whether you have a car payment
or not
yeah yeah and so yeah that's that's
straight up that's a straight up
liability dude that's got to be cleared
how much does she owe on her car
34 000. holy moly okay what do you guys
make
uh we're both making pretty equal money
right just below a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars each okay good that's
good okay so you can clear this off real
fast
yes and will that be it Alex no credit
card debt personal loans anything
no that's they're only good okay awesome
and then how much were you guys having
savings just in liquid cash if you
combine I don't keep a lot of cash on
hand I have about 25
000 in cash okay
I've been saving
um in ETS and retirement accounts how
much in non-retirement do you have
uh 355 000. well done sir good job well
done so when you get married when you
come home from the honeymoon ride check
pay off her car if she doesn't already
have the money to do it before then
okay that's step one
step two is allocate an emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses
uh out of something just say earmark
that that fund right give me the twenty
five thousand dollars that can be our 25
000 that can be whatever your emergency
fund is yeah and then everything else I
would throw at your down payment so
you've got a healthy down payment
non-retirement all goes at the down
payment
really yeah
okay and you're you're almost gonna have
a house paid off I mean what price range
home would you buy
well we live in a very high cost of
living area yes you do really the only
neighborhoods that you would want to buy
in here and kind of the entry level
homes there are 750 and above yeah
that's probably right I don't disagree
with that yeah
and you got so you're gonna have what
300 Grand to put down give or take
well she has money too oh how much has
she got
so probably I have I'd say a net worth
with retirement and and brokerage of
around 625k yeah
um and she has combined worth of around
350. okay but we're using only
non-retirement we would not use
retirement for how much non-retirement
cash can she get a hold of
she has 80k okay and you got 300. and
some change and we got to clear up a car
loan and we gotta have an emergency fund
and so you can put down you know 400k
give or take on a 700 000 house you make
300 you're gonna pay off your house
really fast
that's cool I guess I from I'm from the
Midwest where you know houses cost two
hundred thousand dollars and the idea
yeah but you don't live there
the idea of just crawling to a bank and
you know in A bank's 500 Grand or
something is just kind of a lot to
undertake well I mean if you buy 700 and
you put down 400
you only have a 350 and you make 300. so
you're gonna knock that out in what
three years or four years
and you'll have it free and clear
and your young rich people then with
paid for everything oh my gosh your net
worth will be over a million dollars
easy what's causing you to be hesitant
Alex
uh you don't want to go all in on a
house
yeah
yeah I've been you know saving slowly
investing every check are you renting
now
yes okay well if you want to rent you
can rent it's a bad long-term Play
Because 100 of the time rents go up
yeah and so it's a bad language I know
but I mean short term if you guys want
to rest a little bit and pile up a big
old publication pay cash for the house
and you want to take two or three years
and do that I'm okay if you want to go
that way
y'all are in a better situation than
that so go ahead and get the equity and
yeah start looking at home ownership
because you guys are in that position
fair enough I don't borrow money
um and and so if I were in your shoes
we'd be just continuing we would knock
the car out we build the emergency fund
we take the 300 and the 80 and put them
together and we'd say all right we're
going to chunk everything on here a
couple hundred a year we're gonna live
on 100 make 300 and uh you know pretty
quick I'm gonna pay cash for a house
because I don't borrow money for
anything ever and that's how Sharon and
I would have to do it because that's the
only way we do it if you want to be that
guy that's completely freakish and
wonderful I love it that's going to get
you richer even faster
yeah actually but it's hard to talk
people into doing that so I didn't think
I was I didn't go there yeah but you
know you called out you know you called
Alex to ask about you know are we in a
position to buy a house and the answer
is yes I mean yeah you guys are in an
incredible position you've done the hard
work yeah so now the back half of owning
the home is gonna be like oh yeah we'll
just pay it off in a really short period
of time and then you guys have your
income and it's just yours at that point
I mean it's pretty incredible Boston
single family
residents in a good neighborhood is a
better investment than a UTF okay you're
gonna make more money on it so it's not
a bad investment this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
thank you
foreign
personality is my co-host today if
you're in the Nashville area come and
visit us we're just south in Franklin
Tennessee our lobby is open and we do
the show live on the glass from one to
four central time every day Monday
through Friday three hours of broadcast
and uh usually there's 50 to 200 folks
hanging out and watching the show it's
completely free and it's as is the
wonderful coffee and the homemade
chocolate chip cookies the other thing
that happens here in the lobby is we
have this little stage called the debt
free stage and on that stage right now
is Maggie and Patrick hey guys how are
you good how are you welcome welcome
good to have you where do you guys live
Annapolis Maryland all right and you're
all the way to Nashville to do a
debt-free scream how much are you paid
off 91
320 now can you say that 91 322 I love
it all right and how long did this take
13 months wow and your range of income
during that time
um we started right around 1 35 and then
um 1 45. cool what do you all do for a
living
I'm a math coach in elementary school
work with teachers find fun ways to
teach math all day long it's a good time
that's awesome that's a good gig yeah
um I'm home with the kids and then I
also own a photography business and that
was kind of a big part of the story as
well as to how we got our income shovel
up and um used my business to really get
started good what kind of debt was the
91 000 mostly student loans mostly
students we had small we had small
credit card debts
um we had to purchase like a new water
softener system for our house when that
went out we had to get a brand new HVAC
system
so we had lots of small little things
and they do they just pile up on you and
we just wanted to do something about it
and give it how long you guys been
married uh it'll be 10 years in
September if you're kind of going along
pretty normal and then something
happened what changed the story
um so I I remember having so we had
um our second child and just feeling
like you know why do we have like no
extra money to like enjoy life go out to
dinner or it just felt like we were
always just so like tight with money
um and I heard about you I think at the
time I thought we only had like fifty
thousand dollars in debt because all I
was thinking about was my student loans
um and so I was talking to some friends
and they're like have you heard of Dave
Ramsey this was probably like seven
years ago
um and I looked you up on Google and I
immediately was like oh my gosh we have
to do this and I kind of like shoved it
down his throat and he was like whoa
whoa you know like slow down
um so needless to say we didn't really
get started right away I think we kind
of like sat on it for a while and like
um then in 2020 we really decided to to
start doing it covet was a wake up
um you I think so
um
I think it was just yeah I think we had
more time to like actually talk about
like what do we want for our future and
um you know like a lot of people say
you're not going out to eat anyway so it
was kind of a you know the right time to
get started
um so we started in 2020 and then so
Dave I actually called uh about a year
ago I called into the show
um we were contemplating on whether or
not we should sell our car to really
like get some momentum
and I explained to you uh that you know
we had been chipping away but
um we even though we got started in 2020
at the end of that year we had our third
child and he was just he had a lot of
health issues when he was a baby
um so that following year 2021 I mean we
completely like fell off the wagon we
were like you know Dave who we were just
like back to like normal life not
budgeting just really just surviving
um because like I said it was just a
really tough year yeah
um and when I called and asked you about
it you were just very encouraging you
know you were so kind and compassionate
and you said you know you've been
through the ringer but now it's time for
you guys to like get back on and you've
got this and that was just really like
what I what we needed to hear
um in order to to get this done so step
back into the saddle and finish yep yep
and it feels surreal to be there yeah
yeah because 13 years ago I mean yeah
for for a solid Year you guys were doing
it so what was the hardest part of the
past year because you guys were in and
out of the plan a little bit but doing
it consistently for for a solid year yep
what was the thing that was like oh my
gosh this is this is difficult just the
the small little achievements that we
were making
um I think she called I think you
actually said we had 80 something
thousand dollars a debt at that point I
think you said there's no need to sell
your car we only owed 10 grand on it
it'll eventually go away
um we did sell the car then we were down
to 70 and then I had student loans we
were just paying off just the small
amounts at a time I think we were done
with Home Depot and we were done with
the you know the airline tickets like
the previous caller said about an hour
ago
um so we were we were down to like two
big chunks of money
and we just kind of you know we went
back and forth
um with uh with the housing market at
where it's it where it is right now
we need a bigger house and we want to
switch the kids into a different School
District so we did so we bit the bullet
and we sold our house and we paid off
Maggie's student loans we paid off my
student loans it was a really hard
decision we really did think about it
like so many we went back and forth so
much like do we just stay here and take
another year to finish paying all this
off or do we just sell and the Annapolis
Market is still really hot we listed on
Friday and then we were under contract
on Sunday for 50 000 over asking wow so
we're like okay this was obviously the
right decision I mean it is hard and
moving is painful just it's just
stressful but we're in the school
district that we want to be in now and
we just signed for a um a two-year lease
to pay to save up more because for you
guys sure and then you can use that time
to get ready to purchase again yeah in
the right district and in the meantime
you're clear yeah well done thank you
does it feel as good as we were
imagining
fantastic I know that she started this
and just along the way every time you
know she got out her little app and she
swiped up and we said okay that's gone
that's gone that's gone and then we did
her huge sorry her huge student loan
payment that was like forty eight
thousand dollars but that was gone and
we still have you know
a big chunk of money to put down our
future house but we do we really want
the bigger house and we just need a
little bit more to save up and we know
we can do it and we want to do it the
right way I mean in a lot of ways it's
kind of like we're starting over you
know
um we made a huge mess we cleaned it up
and you know we are we're starting this
new Journey
um with so much more knowledge and um
and now we have like goals you know and
we just never used to talk about it we
never could really Envision you know
what what the future was going to look
like and now it's like all we do we can
actually like dream and we can set goals
and Achieve them and um it's called hope
yeah yeah so good okay tell me about
your photography business because you
said that was a big part of getting some
of this debt paid off yeah so I was
pretty much just like staying at home
with the kids and I worked like a little
like part-time two-day a week job and it
just wasn't bringing in any money and I
had always done photography like as a
hobby and so I'm like well you know
maybe I'll start like a Facebook page or
I'll make like a little website and see
where it goes um and it completely
exploded it turns out I'm not bad at it
so I do weddings I have a studio where I
do like newborns and everything
so yeah it's been it's been so amazing
and just way more successful than I ever
could have imagined that's so fun yeah
that's so great and then added to the to
the journey of of having helping pay off
the debt yeah yeah right yeah
thank you thank you so much you're
completely free was it worth it oh my
gosh absolutely absolutely absolutely
and people I think you know when we talk
about it with you know our friends I
think people just can't really
understand like wow you would sell your
house to get out of debt and it's like
when you want something that bad you
know you'll you'll make it happen
um the inner peace is just oh by the way
you're making a move you need to make
anyway yeah exactly exactly there's
nothing unintelligent about this at all
it's very wise it's very wise all the
way around way to go you guys so great
you guys congratulations hey we got the
live and give box for you the baby steps
millionaires book Total Money Makeover
book and the financial peace membership
you guys are impressive way to go Heroes
thank you I'm proud of you 91 000 paid
off in 13 months including the sale of
the car and the house 135 to 145 income
Maggie and Patrick from Annapolis
Maryland count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one
I told you you could do it this is the
Ramsay show
[Music]
our scripture of the day Philippians 4
13 I can do all things through Christ
who strengthens me Mary Kay Ash said
aerodynamically the Bumblebee shouldn't
be able to fly
but the bumblebee doesn't know it so it
goes on flying anyway Rachel Cruz Ramsay
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Brad is in Lexington
hey Brad welcome to the Ramsay show
hey how's it going better than we
deserve brother how can we help
so uh I am a 32 year old pharmacist and
I have 50 000 in the checking account
uh 21 000 in a money market account
and 27 000 in a Roth R.A in Vanguard
Total market mutual fund
um so I had a large amount of cash saved
up and about a year ago I found some
land and a prime location to put a
pharmacy so I bought it cash
um and I was ready to go I was approved
for the construction loan and then about
seven months ago I got diagnosed with
cancer and I'm sorry that's okay and how
you doing it now I'm I'm intermission
now good good
but it wiped out a lot of my savings so
what I said earlier is all I've got
um I've got 187 thousand dollars in
student loans for my doctorate degree
and I'm approved for a five hundred
thousand dollar construction loan for
the pharmacy and I have a three hundred
thousand dollar line of credit to fund
it until it's profitable I was just
wanting to get an honest opinion of my
financial situation see what you guys
think I should do
foreign
Brad well you've you've been through
you've been through a lot and how much
um you said you bought the lands before
the diagnosis how much was how much is
the land
okay fifty thousand dollars for it okay
and then I did about
70 000 of work to the land
okay
um
well I don't borrow money and I don't
teach people to borrow money and every
time you borrow money you increase risk
you have 187 000 in debt and you're
talking about going another 300 000 in
debt you're gonna end up a million
dollars in the hole running a pharmacy
that does not sound like a probability
of success to me that sounds like an
accident looking for a place to happen
uh it sounds like a dream that could end
up being more of a nightmare and I'm not
a dream killer but I love killing
nightmares
yeah so um so I want you I want you to
live this dream in some way but I would
beg you to do it in a way that involves
a lot less risk than what you've got
today what you're describing how much
are you how much are you making now Brad
170 000. 170 okay I would I would uh
sell the land and I would pay off the
debt the student loan debt and then I
would begin to save and uh think about
how I'm going to open a pharmacy for the
least amount that doesn't involve a
building in other words what you
described to me is about 70 percent real
estate and about 30 percent business you
could go find a closed Walgreens and
rent it
from that landlord and with no real
estate cost move in it and start a
pharmacy for a bazillion dollars less
than you're talking about but you're
doing more of a real estate deal that
here than you are a pharmacy deal
yeah well the issue was the place that I
found is a dream location I have yeah
it's also a Nightmare location
yeah
because
the risk here I mean the cash flow
binder putting yourself in from day one
means you have to move a lot of
pharmaceuticals man
that's a lot of little pills I have to
pay that bill
I mean wow
uh I I I from a business perspective I
think you're asking for trouble but
again I love helping people live their
dreams if I were in your shoes I would
want to own my own thing too I've always
run an owned my own business just about
my whole life and so I I'm I'm right
there with you on that but the it's not
the what it's the how that's bothering
me so no I would not do the deal the way
you've outlined it I think you're asking
for trouble yeah I think you're going to
get in a bind and you're going to be
stressed out and it's going to take you
a decade to get your way through this
and I don't want that for you I think
you can sell this land and real quickly
pay be 100 debt free making 170 then you
can start piling up cash and I would
find a building that is not a dream
location that I can rent and and rent
let someone else bear the real estate
costs and I'd start my business in a
rented building for a tenth of what
you're talking about spending yeah and
Brad there's always
when people use language and you kind of
used it in this call of like it's the
dream location it's the only thing when
there starts to be no options and it's
like well this is the only thing I can
do it pins you in a corner to make you
feel like this is the only thing I can
do whether the math makes sense or not
it's the only option and that's not it's
not true and so you have to expand your
options because options are going to be
able you're going to be able to lower
the emotion of the dream location to see
okay what actually is making sense here
and so don't pin yourself in such a
small narrow path of this one thing even
though I get it right I mean like
there's dream locations everywhere like
we all know that and here's the thing
let's do this let's let's take it a step
further okay because here's what we did
at Ramsey all right we start small and
then we move up with cash and we move up
with cash and we we you know we're in a
000 square foot office building right
here I mean that's paid for um we
certainly didn't start there we started
in a rented basement 800 square feet
month-to-month rental we started on a
card table in my living room okay so
what you could do is this
you could do go my way you could say all
right we're going to be debt free and
I'm going to save up 50 to 100 grand and
I'm going to open in an existing
location of some kind where I can rent
the building and all I need is the
pharmacy setup I need the shelving I
need the stock the inventory
um I need the licensing I need to do
that stuff it may not be as good a
location but we're going to get started
so we're going to risk 50 to 100 000 of
cash
not a borrowed money
get that thing working and making
serious money again
and get back up to your income and then
save up and pay cash for the deal that
you're trying to do here or a deal like
you're trying to do here and if you want
to do the dream four hundred thousand
dollars worth of real estate and a
hundred thousand dollars worth of setup
half a million dollars going in you do
that all in cash after you got already
got one up and running because you will
learn so much in your first one that you
pay cash for that will inform doing the
second one wiser and I don't know if we
can stop you or not
but if we can stop you with one phone
call we would stop you for your own good
I it doesn't affect us but I'm begging
you don't do that deal it is so full of
holes it's so full of risk that you
don't see and
um I want you to have a wonderful life I
want you to own your own business but I
do not want it to own you and you are
getting ready to be Shackled hands and
feet when you sign up for all this stuff
and it doesn't feel like it's a risk for
you because all you can see is the
upside because all of us that want to
own our own business are optimists we're
all glass half full people and that's
how our brains work so I'm happy for
your cancer remission yes I'm happy that
you're getting the other side of that
I'm thrilled for you thrilled that you
got a wonderful career making really
good money now clean up your student
loan mess build a basis of life on a
foundation where everything's you know
more grown up and it's less fantasy yeah
and I think it's a good rule of thumb
too for people starting anything
start small you start small because your
your mistakes are going to be smaller
your learnings are gonna like you're
going to be able to it's not these big
fatal mistakes if you are starting
something at the Pinnacle which is a
little bit Brad it's kind of what you're
saying it's like I'm taking out 300 000
I'm going to do a construction loan
build my own I mean you're doing the big
thing
and for some reason if it doesn't start
work you know if it's not working or
there's mistakes to be made those are
magnified because of the scale at which
you're choosing to do it so starting
small on anything is is I'll just tell
you I have built from the ground up
hundreds of millions of dollars in real
estate
hundreds of millions in homes in
commercial buildings in the buildings
that we're in on this campus 100 of the
buildings we built if we were doing them
over we'd do them different yeah and
they were end up being expensive I mean
like you know what I mean like there's
just so much 100 you have unseen
expenses that catch you off guard 100 of
business does not work the way you think
it's going to a hundred out of a hundred
times you just count on it and that
that's what goes with this territory hey
man thanks for the call hope it goes
well for you that puts us out of the
Ramsay show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
thank you
hey it's Rachel Cruz if you like what
you heard in this episode and want to
know more about getting started on the
Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramseysolutions.com and click get
started
[Music]